hi I'm low I'm Julia Michaels and this
is our exclusive behind-the-scenes look
for there's no way
[Music]
the song is so good how did the
collaboration come about so Julie and I
met for the first time a little bit ago
and actually we didn't write the song
that first time we were just kind of
like we just hung out and talked got to
know each other I tend to be a bit
nervous when I meet new people so Sam I
just wanted to sort of just talk and get
to know each other and then like we work
together again a song honestly came like
really quickly and it was like one of
those things where like we we left that
day and like I didn't realize at the
time but it was like mostly done like
the like I would say like the magic or
whatever was like there your first
impression of one another super weird
yeah I don't yeah I'm weird she's got
like she but she has a good taste like
in music look I feel like I definitely
think I was way more awkward than you
were when we first met not true never
true always the most awkward human on
planet
I feel like you guys have this chemistry
though now is that just from today and
filming on this set or is it like a
friendship that's developed over time
it's definitely a friendship that's
developed over time when you write songs
I mean it's a very intimate thing you
get to know a lot about a person in a
very short amount of time it almost
forces you to to have chemistry and then
it's up to you and the other person
[Music]
lyrically what does the song mean to you
guys what do you want people to take
away from it the song is basically about
when you meet somebody and like you just
know that there's something there yeah
and like you don't know when it's gonna
happen but it's yeah there's a feeling
that you have with somebody a specific
somebody and it's the connection
sometimes is so strong but sometimes the
timing is off but it's almost like you
know that it's gonna happen in time it's
just me and it's almost like we knew
that there would be history
[Music]
it's basically we're like we're in a
band together called blurry bodies and
we're on tour and yeah we're just
playing a big show and basically the
videos about being on tour with somebody
and we both have significant others but
you get to know each other and you spend
every day with each other and you start
to feel connected to somebody even
though you know you have a completely
different life outside of it yeah so
what you just saw was basically us
wanting to be together but camp
[Music]
the song together so was this something
that was inspired by one single person
something that you guys have both felt I
think we've probably both felt that I
think a lot of people feel it and they
like never act upon it you know you
probably feel that many times were you
like kind of you meet somebody and
you're like I feel like there might be
something and like maybe nothing's ever
said and you may never see that person
again or maybe you do and it becomes a
thing
[Music]
[Applause]